the world's largest bioluminescent area
an area so big you can see it from space
with unknown to science until 2005 this
was common sailor lore that sometimes
you sail into these areas where the sea
was white and light was glowing up from
below this ship
the reason times is didn't know about it
is they didn't think was possible for
that many micron organisms to be in one
place doing something together but they
were wrong so how did the milky seas
finally get spotted by science well
google helped in 2005 scientist named
Steve Miller was musing over lunch
whether it would even be possible
for a light tinting satellite to see
bioluminescence in the ocean he got home
I started google and came across a 1995
report from the SS Lima the exact words
are the bioluminescence appeared to
cover the sea horizon to Horizon lucky
for Steve Miller as he matched the the
report from the SS Lima with the
satellite data a very clear image began
to resolve there was in fact a
corresponding area of bioluminescence
that wasn't enormous this was the first
hard proof of the milky seas the
bacteria they think causes the milky
seas as a bacterial pond vibe real
Harvey I it doesn't want to scare off
predators it wants to attract fish
because the place that it wants to live
is on the inside of a fish so the amount
of bacteria it would take to make a
glowing area the size of Connecticut is
almost unfathomable it is 40 billion
trillion bacteria if each bacteria were
the size of a grain of sand the grain of
sand would cover the earth 10
centimeters deep the whole earth all
what causes this the truth is they don't
know we don't know yet we don't know how
it forms we don't know what the
conditions are but what we do know is
that it does happen and you know who
else knew it Jules Verne in 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea describes the SS
Nautilus coming across
phenomenon it's likely actually that
jules verne used real ships logs to
describe the milky seas well it may have
taken science until 2005 to find
definitive proof of the milky seas Jules
Verne was eerily scientifically accurate
in 1869 subscribe here and watch more
videos here Siri when was 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea published the answer is
1869 if you have places you've traveled
to that you thought were just the most
amazing thing you've ever seen
hidden wonders you'd like to share with
us please let us know in the comments
follow us on Twitter and tell us there
let us know on Facebook we would love to
hear